finally after months of tough
negotiations european parliament's has
managed to sway member states the e
u--'s outstanding bills will be paid a
first tranche will cover four billion of
a total of nearly 25 billion euros the
reimbursement was a key condition of the
2015 Bridget Jessica que cero Parliament
I before forcing a nausea vomiting agito
no determination anization prayer a
laser scanner limit extreme show
crack-a-lackin' say no head or nay okay
hey Gilda penmanship remote air Sakura
agave dramatic moment on the fact you
happy here for 2015 the MEP secured
additional funding for SMEs Erasmus
research and foreign policy several
parliaments in Europe have already shown
support in favor of recognizing
Palestinian statehood today it was the
turn of em eps to cast their vote in
plenary an overwhelming majority voted
to recognize Palestine but argued this
recognition must go hand in hand with
progress in Israel Palestine peace talks
mep zedge all palestinian factions to
put an end to internal divisions and
condemn israeli settlements which
international law deems illegal
following revelations by the US Senate
of CIA torture notably a prisoners held
in Guantanamo Emmy PS have reopened
their investigation several EU member
states have been directly implicated in
authorizing renditions on their
territories and allegations suggest
their involvement in the torches those
who are responsible in the US but as
well in European states who cooperated
with this program must be held
responsible must be try the now
responsible the law is the same for all
MPs will face on a resolution in plenary
in February Tina regarded for the 2014
looks prize award ceremony Pavel public
offski zaida came away with the European
Parliament's film prize the film takes
viewers on the journey of a young girl
is she sets out to discover her identity
a moving story set against the backdrop
of Europe's painful past the lux prize
rewards the three shortlisted finalists
with subtitling in all 24 EU languages
and screenings in all 28 member states